once upon a time jason kokrak earned a
degree in communications
an admirable field but you see the cj
cup tournament on the pga tour awards
one million seven hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars to the winner
jason kokrak will not be needing to
utilize his mass com major anytime soon
the most lush green space in the desert
answer
shadow creek cj cup providing dazzling
scores here in las vegas sandra shafley
has been at the top of the leaderboard
all week but his score of 18 under par
was not good enough so meet jason kokrak
the 35 year old canadian is a top 60
player in the world
but he's never had a need for a trophy
shelf because he's never won a
tournament
on the pga tour today las vegas changed
his life kokrak
shoots a final round 64. and wins the cj
cup for his first
pga win i i want to say it's uh
you know a little bit of kind of an mgm
ambassador crew
been here in vegas i've got an aunt and
uncle that live here my dad
lived out here for a little while so you
know it kind of feels like home so
and i've played this golf course enough
i should know it by now